السلام عليكم لذكرى من ماتت وهي تعلمني
كيف تكون الحياه لذكرى حياه مليئه بالحب
السعاده والشغف لذكرى قلب احبني مع كل
نبضه وعندما توقف ايقاع قلبي تغير
للابد يوم 26 فبراير 2014 الماما وقف بعد
19 يووم بلغه 49 سنه
قرابه الشهرين من الان خلوني اكون صريحه
معكم وقوفي هون اليوم هو من اصعب الاشياء
اللي عملتها في حياتي اني اشارك قصتي معكم
واني احكي عن ماما بعد بعد هالفتره
القصيره من وفاتها طب ح تسالوني اذا كل
هذا الموضوع صعب عليك ليش عم تعمليه بقول
لكم لاني حاسه بمسؤوليه تجاهكم نحن دائما
منسمع بشوف ونقرا عن قصص ناس مرت بتجارب
صعبه وتعلمت منا كثير بنقول نا تجربتهم
اننا لنتعلم من اخطائهم وما نتعلم
بالطريقه الصعبه بس قليل لنتعظ فانا هون
اليوم على امل لو شفتوا حدا قدامكم بحكي
بنفس لغتكم وعايش بينكم حتكون الدوس اقوى
وسخ لتعيشوا حياه
افضل لا
وه
على عكس اخوتي انا ولدت في البيت فهال
الصوره اخذت بعد ساعه تقريبا من مولدي
حياتي عامه كانت رائعه كانت صعبه بس
طفولتي كانت اكثر من رائعه بحضن ام لم
يخلق لها رب البريه مثيل لما صار عمري تسع
سنين اضطرينا انه ننتقل لهون ومن
يومها وصحه ماما عم تدهور عمليه بعد عمليه
مصيبه تلو الاخوه والحياه عم
بتمر هي صفحه من صفحات مذكرات ماما وانا
في سنه الاخيره من الثانويه اعراض جديده
بدي اتصر عليها هو شعور قاتل مغير للنفس
بلا رجعه شعورك بالعجز عن انك تساعد من
تهبه روحك لو
طلبها عن انك تعرف السبب ورا الالم او
تقدر تخففه ش هو مريت قبل ما نعرف سبب
عناها ومع كل الالم اللي كان
بسببه انتشار مثل هيك مرض كانت تجي لعندي
بالليل تحضني وتقرا لي قران لانام اطمني
انه هي بخير وانه ما في شي حسها اكثر من
نجاحي وتفوقي شهور مرت في اختباراتي
النهائيه كانت عمليه ازاله ورم ماما قائمه
با اختباري التحصيلي اعلنوا الدكاتره انه
الورم في الامعاء خبيث ومن الدرجه الرابعه
يعني ما له علاج
لما بتعرف ان المرضه مصابه في امك غير
قابل للشفاء وان الطريق الممتد امامك هو
طريق العناء والشقاء الكلمات ولاول مره
بتصير بلا
معنى معجزات دائما بتحصلي واني احصل على
هيك معدل بهيك وضع وبالاخص باني ما كنت
اخلص نصف محتوى المواد قبل الامتحان معجزه
بعتبها الله وفقني لها بسبب رضا امي علي
حياتي ميسه ميسه
بشوف التوفيق والتسيير بابسط امور حياتي
اليوميه لانهما برفع ايدي لربي بكون مؤمنه
بكل ذره من وجودي بحفظه
ومحبته فيني لو كل واحد فينا تذكر عدد
المرات اللي الله فيها استجاب دعائه ولما
حرمه كان لمصلحته بحياته ما ح يدخل ياس
لقلوبنا ثلاث سنين مرت والمرض بتطور كل
يوم هي ايدين ماما قبل شهرين من وفاتها قب
عشو متتابعه من النوم في
المستشفى الامعاء سدت تماما ما في عمليه
بتساعدها الدكات قالوا لنا كل اللي بده
يعملوه هو انه يغزوها وريديا يستنوا
لاعضائها تتوقف الواحد تلو الاخر لحتى
الموت يكون هو النهايه شغله اشهر بس مو
اكثر حزنا من الالم الجاي لا يوصف ما كان
في شي بسكنه الا المورفين قلت بسكنه مو
بخليها
تنام كنت انام معها في المستشفى واحكي
معها عن كل شيء صاير معي واضحك معها عن
مواقف غبيه عملتها بس بكل ضحكه كان في الف
انه لانها ما كانت عم تفهمني عيونها كانت
غير مركزه خاليه فاقده لحياه كنت اتجاهل
الاعراض لحتى اج اليوم اللي سالتني فيها
وين ق وانا كنت ماسكه بايدها وقتها تاكدت
انه وصل لدماغه كان عم ياخذها مني وقت ب
لحظتها ولاول مره دعيت يا رب احيها ما
دامت الحياه خير لها ومتها ما دام الموت
رحمه فيها علاقتي بماما مميزه ماما هي
الهامي حافزي
للحياه ما في شيء بعمله اذا ما حسيت انه ح
يسعدها بطريقه او اخرى من غير تشجيعها
ومباركتها فالم سالتني وين الاء الالم
اللي اجاني كان بسبب احساسي اني فقدت
حافزي للحياه فقدت ماضيي حاضري مستقبلي ما
كنت بعرف اذا حاقدر الاقي الطريق بعدها او
لا اربع ليالي مت من هذك الليله وفكرنا
نطالع ماما من المستشفى ليومين او اثنين
كتغيير
لها كنت مرهقه جدا انك توافق مريض في
مستشفى يعني انه ما في نوم هذا غير الدوام
وال
اختبارات اول شيء عملته لما وصلت على
البيت اني نمت وتركتها مع اخوي مع انه
بحياتي ما نمت قبل ماما قبل ما اتطمن
عليها واسالها اذا بقدر اعملها شيء حتى
بعد هيك بالفتره الاخيره كنت استناها
لاتنام بس بهديك الليله خليت ضعفي يخذلني
الله خلقني قويه لسبب وبهديك الليله خليت
ضعفي
يخذلني فجاتني على صلاه الفجر مشيت معها
لغرفتها اسا عدها تصلي خمس دقائق كمان روح
امي كانت عادت لخالقها شفتها وهي عم بتموت
شفتها روحها عم تخرج كنت ناديها ماما لا
تتركيني ماما خليك معي ماما
ماما
بندم
شكرا بندم كل لحظه كل يوم يوم مع كل نفس
على استسلامي في هذك الليله على تخاز لي
عمري وانا قويه ليله ضعف وكان الموضوع
انتهى كنت دائما اسمع بمقوله لا تستسلم
فانت لا تعلم كم انت قوي من خط النهايه بس
بحياتي ما حسيت فيها اد هيك ساعات ممكن
تكون تفصلك عن هدفك لا تستسلموا وخليكم
اقوياء لما بتشوف اب امك الحياه تضاءل
امامك لانه ما في شيء ممكن تاخذه منك اكثر
من هيك بصير الموضوع ان تكون او لا تكون
وانا اخترت انه اكون انه افعل كل الاشياء
اللي بعرف انها بتحبها بانه امتلك الشجاعه
لاجل امي ابي لاجل ابي اخواتي
اخوتي كلهم كانوا يتطلعون الي ليكتسبوا
القوه وبقوه تصرفت قوه احتجت لانهض من
فراشي لامسح دموع عي يقابل عالم موحد جدا
في
غيابها كان انتظرتني مهمه صعبه طول عمري
وانا عايشه في عباءه امي لما نزعت عني
العباءه بلحظه كان من انتظرتني مهمه صعبه
باني امضي من دون حمايه باني الاقي
الالهام والقوه في داخلي بس لقيتهم بحضن
اختي الصغيره اللي كانت ايديها اول من
وصللي بعد لحظات من وفاه ماما حضنتني
كانها عم بتقول لي انا هون انا
محتاجتك منهك اللحظه وانا كل يوم بداد قوه
وايمان بانه اللي حصل لي لحكمه بانه كل
الالم اللي بحس فيه وح احس فيه كل يوم
بيمضي من غير ماما بخليني اشعر بالعالم
اكثر بيعطيني طاقه دافعه
للتغير خليني اساعد الناس احبهم باخطائهم
وعيوبهم بضعفهم ونقصهم لحتى اشوف الجمال
فيهم واساعدهم يشوفوا تميزهم لاقول لهم
انه القوه والالهام اذا ما نبع من الداخل
وكانوا معين لا ينضب بحياتنا ماح ننجز
ونغير العالم للافضل
لاخر يوم قبل مافه ماما وانا لسه كنت
بداوم كت طبيعيه لدرجه انه كثير من حوالي
تفاجوا لما عرفوا بوضعي لا مع انه الضغط
اللي كان علي هائل بس ما استسلمت له لانه
سقف احلامي عالي كنت كل يوم اعمل اللي علي
والله ما بخيب مخلص في طلبه رابع يوم بعد
وفاه ماما داومت وما سمحت نفسي باني اتخاز
او اتراجع لسع كلمات ما بتني باذني انت
بتقدري حتى لما كنت معها في الاختبارات
النهائيه الفصل راح وكانت عم تحتضر كثير
ناس قالوا لي اعتزي عن الفصل ما راح تمشي
هيك وهي كانت تقول لي مالك عزر ما تكملي
وتفوقي انت
بتدوي
في فرص بهذا العالم اكبر منه نضيعها بدنا
او خوفنا صفه العظماء هي المبادره بهم
يعرفوا شو بدهم وبيعملوا ليحصلوا عليه
لانه لازم نعيش اللحظه اللي نحن فيها لانه
هي اللحظه هي اجمل ما ممكن ان تكون عليه
الحياه لانه عباره بكره احلى جميله جدا بس
احيانا نعتمد على بكره كثير بننسى نعيش
لحظتنا لو بساعدك انك تفكر انه بكره ممكن
يكون كثير اسوا لتعيش حصتك فمعلش فكر هيك
مهما كان وضعك الحالي سيء عيشه واستمتع
فيه لانه اللي حفظك ونجاك من امور مضت كنت
تحسبها القاسمه ان حصلت بيحفظك من هي ومن
اللي بعدها نصيحه من شخص كان بتمنى يستمتع
باخر لحظات من وفاه امه عن انه
يفقدها شكرا كوب قهوه دافي بين ايدي بس
الطفل ريحه المطر كلمه ود من شخص غريب ان
اكت فلاف مثل هذا من اختي كلهم بيصنعوا
يومي لانه انت بتختار شلون تطلع على
الامور لانه انا اخترت انه اامن انه اليوم
الكون كله عم يعمل لاجلي وانه لسه عم حضر
لي الاجمل لبكره
حب حب الله وحب الحياه ميراث غالي مثه من
ماما حتى لما فقدت كل شعرها نصف وزنها
وقوتها
كانت تلبس احلى ما عندها تحط شعرها
المستعار وترقص وتغني كلمتها الدائمه كانت
انا بحب الضحك
فضحكوا لما بتكون بهيك وضع توقعات عن
الناس عنك بتكون سيئه كنت احس بالعيون عم
بتراقبني تسائل متى حيكون انهياري لانه
بالنسبه لهم هذا الشيء كان حاصل لا محاله
حتى بعضهم كان يغير طريقه لما يشوفني حتى
ما انها بين ايديه لما قلت لهم اني حكون
متحدثه في تدكس بعد اسبوعين بس من وفاه
ماما الكل قاللي مجنونه رح تنهاري راح
تبكي على المسرح وما راح تستحملي قلت لهم
ما راح ابكي لانه عندي رساله لازم اوصلها
لاني عايشه لها بتكون باقصى حالات انجازك
وانت عايش لفكره وانا هون اليوم بتمنى اني
وصلت
رسالتي شكرا
شكرا انا هون اليوم بتمنى اني وصلت رسالتي
وما
بكيت ادعو دائما واصنعني على عينك واصنعني
لنفسك يا الله دعائي المفضل لاخدم ام
احبها ان انا فقدت امتي الاولى وهي ماما
فما زالت لدي امه بتعداد مليارين اوصتني
بها امتي الاولى لن اتخذل في خدمتها انت
خليفه الله في الارض لديك امانه في هذا
العالم فقم اليها
شكرا